well we begin in Moscow Where The Heart
of the Russian capital's financial
district has been hit by drone strikes
it happened early on Sunday morning and
one person was injured in the blast no
other injuries or deaths have been
reported part of the facade of a
50-story skyscraper though was damaged
my friends and I rented an apartment to
come here and unwind and at some point
we had an explosion and it was like a
wave everyone jumped and then there was
a lot of smoke and you couldn't see
anything from above You Could See Fire
well this is the first attack to hit
moscow's Financial District which houses
Russia's top companies it's also the
first time that drones have targeted
this particular area of the city the
mayor has blamed Ukraine
while Russia's defense Ministry says
three Ukrainian drones were shot down in
this Dawn attack that includes one
brought down in the city's outskirts
vinokovo International Airport was also
briefly closed for about an hour and the
airspace over Moscow and surrounding
areas was also temporarily closed well
for more on all of this let's speak to
Daniel Hawkins he is in Moscow Daniel a
very bold attack there on the capital
this morning talk us through how it all
unfolded
but absolutely you could say this attack
is unprecedented as you say in terms of
how bold it is and how close it is to at
the heart of the Russian Capital it took
place in Moscow city which is around
five minutes drive from this very studio
in fact you can see most of the towers
of Moscow city
um from the other window just on the
other side
um of this apartment that took place as
you say in the early hours involving
three drones as the Russian Ministry of
Defense said one of which was brought
down outside this the limits of the city
and two further drones crashing into a
non-residential uh building complex in
the heart of Moscow City now the IQ
quarter as it's called where this attack
took place is actually home not only to
luxury apartments and businesses it's
also home to multiple government agency
offices the telecommunication economy
and trade ministry as well some of
Europe's tallest buildings the second
and third tallest buildings in Europe
are nearby as well so this is a very
high profile oil area and had this
attack of course taken place not on a
Saturday night in the early hours but in
the daytime there is no doubt at all
that this would have caused many more
casualties than it did than just one of
those injuries reported now those
buildings have been evacuated the ones
which were damaged the functioning of
lucavor and the moscow's other main
airports are now back to normal but
certainly the scale of those explosions
the dramatic images of those flames in
Moscow City in the very heart of the
Russian Capital left many people in that
residential apartment building and
Beyond as well in shock I'm sure I've
been wanting to ask you about that
Daniel because now that the war has
really truly reached the streets of
Moscow how are people there feeling
well slowly this is almost you could say
becoming the new normal for moscovites I
think for most people as this conflict
dragged on
um to start with it was something that
was rather far away something that
didn't affect people directly aside from
perhaps some of the economic impacts and
as this conflict has progressed uh In
Waves this has come closer and closer to
home the shelling of those border areas
between Russia and Ukraine uh the broad
regions of belgorod and kuruksh then the
mobilization of course which affected
several uh groups of the population now
this is very much a case of what could
happen next people just don't know
because if areas like Moscow City if
even the Kremlin as we saw those images
several months ago can be targeted in
such a bold manner anywhere and anyone
potentially could be next and I think
questions are going to be asked by
people as to how this happened and
people are used to seeing enhanced
security measures the air defenses for
example on the roof of the Moscow
Ministry of Defense police with
anti-drone rifles at events very strict
laws governing the use and the launch of
drones not only in Moscow but Beyond in
Russian regions as well yet somehow
these drones have managed to evade these
defenses and strike at the very heart of
moss it very much highlights the
increasing risk and cost of the conflict
potentially for the Russian population
and I think official figures and media
figures will use this as evidence to
cite this attack as evidence as they say
of Ukrainian aggression towards Russia
and of the need to complete the aims of
what they call the special military
operations so very much questions will
be asked of the mod as to how these
drones got through if these attacks
could be stopped in future and will
leave many people wondering where could
be struck next it could be their house
it could be their office very much a
feeling of uncertainty this morning in
Moscow Daniel Hawkins there in the
Russian capital for us thank you so much
Daniel